let's talk about us some lootcrate this
video is sponsored by of course loot
crate and make sure you guys stay tuned
at the end so I can hook y'all up with a
one month free subscription to this
right here what despise the video but I
still gotta hook y'all up like this hey
what is going on YouTube now today I've
got my something special I think I'll
use my hands too much when I speak don't
I always look like I'm not the freestyle
battle the hell out of somebody but I
don't know what I'm gonna say next
we're not coming you go stick and we go
we go what i'ma walk away [ __ ] but yes
thanks to you guys and your continued
support to get me to a million Lucretius
hit me up to do a quick little product
review on this right here shiny now for
those you jackasses the doctor but
lootcrate is a monthly subscription
service that hooks you up with some dope
gamer slash geek gear now you guys know
that I only support and let people
sponsor their stuff on my channel that I
support hundred percent HU and an IV so
if you guys are gonna cut yourself one
of these monthly subscriptions make sure
that you go to the link below right here
and yes it's gonna also be in that
description box below so click that link
and order that if you want and make sure
you guys stay tuned to the end of video
so I can tell you guys how to get a
discount with a personalized promo code
because you [ __ ] look cheap as hell
just like me and there's nothing wrong
with being cheap I'll go to the store go
to the sale rack say hell with that go
right to the cleaners say hell with that
turn the clearance thing and ask for a
discount discount level agent now the
theme of this box that I received and
I'm going to show you is rewind and
every month
yes the box is our theme so let's take a
look Ian okey-dokey first up we got this
dope little magazine that we got here
yes yes yeah I don't thing about this
magazine is that if you look into the
box and you don't know what's going on
this little magazine is gonna explain
what you got the history behind it and
why it relates the theme of rewind so
it's kind of dope you know thing so if
you guys can't read learn to read you a
literate best and in fact there's a
little bit of a history lesson in this
magazine as well
children this right here is a cassette
tape and if you don't know what a
cassette tape is you need to do the
world a favor and pop yourself in the
penis yes kids we used to actually
listen to music on this ancient artifact
you know seriously I'm not gonna lie I
hate when I share stuff with people and
they look at me like I'm old as hell
what's that this is a pen you dumb Shh
but if you were a rapper in the 90s you
should already know what a cassette tape
is is where you will record all your
mixtapes
and your broken dreams next up we got
ourselves this dope ass black skinny tie
from black tie
yo this is actually a pretty legit yeah
rock this right here I personally love
skinny ties but you know I'm kind of fat
so like a regular tie already looks like
a skinny tie I mean do you ever see like
a 400-pound do wear a skinny tie she
look like a shoestring with a knot in it
next up look at this right here might be
Sokka looks like we got ourselves a
bullfrog t oj son Voltron is actually
one of those og animes I used to watch
when I was a kid I don't mind being like
Power Rangers of stuff you know before I
think before power right and I got to
say I thoroughly enjoyed the fact that
it's black makes me look like a retired
ninja right now tell me I look cute so
you want to do me touch me dirty that's
actually in the box it comes with these
8-bit Stunna shades as well which would
go well with this piece
tell me right now I don't look like a
sex offender I don't know if I can walk
out in the hood and wear an 8-bit
glasses you know not get my ass beat but
if you don't live in a ghetto area this
is perfectly fine just make sure you
know hood suckers around you there
Robbie quick oh [ __ ] no you didn't you
don't get you don't get you don't get me
that's the Cantonese version when I was
a kid I was a huge Star Wars fan no joke
I'm not just saying this because it's in
the box
I love Return of the Jedi but I remember
I also broke as a kid I couldn't afford
the lightsaber toy so I'll just get a
broom and just the air only
all the kids in the neighborhood thought
I was special
well I proved you wrong because next up
look what we have here you know one of
the bigger things that's been popping up
in the past like five years are these
action figurines this one oh my god what
the hell happened it's a Doctor Who the
Tendo cartridge if you guys don't know
what nintendo is this is what it
originally looked like you freaking
young sons a check it out I'm gonna
build him leave it oh this will gotta
get son what's up good who are you
Doctor Who it is actually pretty dope
but I'm kind of hyped about this
remember back in the day when you had
these Nintendo cartridges and then you
will blow into them and all your friends
be like why are you giving it a blow job
uh-huh no just me I actually have a
watch to show Doctor Who bye hurts been
around for like a bajillion seasons and
it's about a dude that's in a time
machine that goes time machining and
last but not least we got this pretty
fly notebook in notebook comic book
format we don't you know what the dopest
thing about this is it's actually a
comic book so you could draw your notes
this is actually perfect for me or I
could have used this when I was in high
school because I used to never write
notes I just doodle I used to always
draw goldfishes or titties or goldfish
is sucking on titties but yo this was
pretty dope and thanks loot crate for
hooking it up and stay tuned at the end
because I'm a teacher not to get a
discount on the monthly subscription and
on top of that one of y'all are going to
get a free loot crate on this upcoming
month yes yo look right no you just did
that
yo it turns into a Nintendo system the
back of the magazine is a Nintendo
controller huh do I calm yourself down
David you want a dog you don't like
games like women you don't I was going
on YouTube yes of course that was a
sponsored and supported video for loot
crate yelling stupid even before lucre
hit me up I actually have been using
loot crate I use that monthly
subscription so I can hook it up with my
homies kids and they love it because
they actually think that I love them so
yes if you guys do want to cop your loot
crate monthly subscription it is only
1395 a month to get you guys some epic
gaming and geek gear February's loot
crate if you sign up actually has an
exclusive tabletop game yes so remember
I told you guys bye
and in this video I was gonna hook you
guys up with a discount well here it is
I want you guys to click that link in
the description box below and you can
enter the promo code David so comedy to
get 10% off and for one of my lucky
subscribers you are gonna get a one
month free subscription just by taking
this video there's going to be a link
that you can tweet I want you to click
that and tweet it and also hashtag David
so comma T hashtag loot crate and I will
be picking at random who is going to win
and I will get your email and thus loot
crate will hook you up with a monthly
free subscription and for the person
that wins will get one month free all
you have to do is send me your email
after I pick you and yes loot crate's
gonna hook it up that's right people I
don't do these promo stuff without
giving you something free come on now I
like that you and I would but once again
thank you Luke rate for giving me and
all of my viewers the opportunity to
check you guys out and I will see you
guys Wednesday and Sunday always
Wednesday and Sunday Wednesday and
Sunday Wednesday is Sunday Wednesday and
Sunday what tinnie it's a tie it's a
black tie from plankton from plaque that
was his kid in our neighborhood that
[ __ ] his pants and we used to call him
Chu caca